it was on a visit to meet Canadian
veterans that Prince Charles allegedly
made the unguarded and off-camera
remarks talking to a Jewish Museum
volunteer who'd fled the Nazis and lost
family members in the Holocaust he said
and now Putin is doing just about the
same as Hitler a reference it seems to
the recent annexation of Crimea and the
ongoing unrest in the east and south of
Ukraine the remarks are likely to prove
diplomatically destructive with the
Russians particularly proud of their
role in defeating Hitler and the role of
Crimea intentionally chosen this month
to showcase the country's World War two
victory celebrations and it could prove
personally embarrassing the prince who's
met the Russian president before most
notably during a state visit in 2003 is
due to again at d-day commemorations
early next month Clarence House is
refusing to comment but stress the
prince would not make a public political
statement during a private conversation
at home British politicians have reacted
with concern Labour's mic gapes tweeting
in a constitutional monarchy policy and
diplomacy should be conducted by
Parliament and government monarchy
should be seen and not heard
this is not the first time Charles who
is due back in Britain later this week
has caused a political Rao though this
latest one looks set to sour
anglo-russian relations yet further